♪♪
Dad, why are you doing
this to us?
♪♪
Dina:
Why is it such a big secret?
♪♪
Sh-shh...
(Sirens wail)
Because we have a problem.
♪♪
What kind of problem?
(Tires skidding)
Allie:
You know the kind of problem,
that you think, Okay,
first glance, that looks pretty
bad.
Margot (whispers):
The kids could get hurt.
They're not gonna get hurt.
They're with us.
Ooh, that's what I'm worried
about.
♪♪
If I just sit down and think
about it.
♪♪
(Car door shuts)
Allie:
I might be able to figure a way
out of it.
♪♪
We don't have that kind of
problem.
♪♪
Allie:
We make the move
and we start again.
♪♪
Wait.
This is gonna be an adventure.
♪♪
Dina:
I'm scared.
♪♪
Absolutely.
(Sirens wail)
♪♪
If it didn't feel that way.
It wouldn't be an adventure.
(Sirens wail)
Allie:
We need to go.
Come on.
(Sirens wail)
♪♪